you guys have critiqued me for long
enough
so i finally made the investment of
buying a new camera
i'm still tweaking the settings i'm
still trying to figure it out but i
think it looks pretty crisp
it's got nice saturation nice nice color
balance
nice frame rate side roll the intro
[Music]
[Music]
video idea now that felix is actually a
minecraft veteran he should react to
this video to experience the level of
frustration we all felt when it came out
this has a million views people mocking
me
oh why does he not open
tonight oh it needs to be night oh my
god
i played the game when he was in alpha
you know i'm sort of a veteran i don't
need you
to tell
so how do i build a twig
a twig a branch
a stick i'm close i'm almost there
hey okay
there's 10 minutes of this i'll
definitely react to that that's
hilarious
we've come so far gamers we got the
crisp quality
video it kind of loses its charm you
know
all these youtubers getting all these
big crews and expensive equipment
they used to just start so simple but
now we have the whole production behind
these videos
british accent american accent me a
european who learn english from youtube
i get called out all the time here in uk
you're american no no i'm not american i
just watch too many movies i don't know
what to tell you
and then they're always like good i
don't like americans
i'm like me too i'm joking americans
i just say it so that they won't dislike
me okay
can i can i just use that please yeah
all right
one of my first collaborators was uh sea
bass
and a lot of people kept writing him
like you need to collab you need to
collab and it's kind of awkward because
we're not in touch anymore and
nothing happened but it's so like i
don't know how you tell the internet
some people just
don't stay friends forever
what happened what happened it's the
same with markiplier it's like
yeah we're just not as close as we used
to be this it's kind of awkward when
everyone online is just going like you
need to go everywhere
bro the last guy i collaborated with
literally quit his youtube career
i'm not collaborating with anyone ever
okay i'm collaborating with felix
shelbert because he seems real
is everything that she has pink what
that
i know this oh god i just saw the camera
itself
uh yes i have coke in there we have
nowhere to store it okay
did felix trap you in water too [ __ ] you
what a cat
you're just a sheep sheep clone get it
guys
just hear me out oh wow well scythe has
been suspiciously missing for a few days
so this would actually make sense scythe
i need you to stop editing and be my leg
standing
another pun intended thank you
what's wrong with you know
stop it's very cute though good camera
quality good mic
quality good resolution after all these
years
i'm an innovator i'm pushing that game
y'all go to 8k i go to 420 [ __ ]
don't tempt me i might go to 240 if this
continues
random woman on the street her toddler
me trying to make him smile
hey look ken ken gets to be in a meme
now
hooray shout out after all these years
finally i had the mode why does jack
look so [ __ ] hard dude
pug owners look at my little angel
he's a little pig himself honestly he
snores like what
what the [ __ ] is that a cursed creature
that draws strength from killing
pregnant women
edgar doesn't look like that come on
edgar has been replaced by a multi-pack
of coke
now that my camera quality is so good
this is how he will actually look like
so i can't show him
the leaks pick up here's new camera oh
you found it
what the hell guys this is so
embarrassing now i'm still using their
this is
uh that's like a 5 000 pound camera that
i'm using
okay just a bit loud
[Music]
nice okay i've been thinking about this
for a long time
we need a new song because it's just a
rip-off
of of jack's films and it started as a
meme
but now that we've gone so far into this
i feel like we need to rebrand the white
right
i think it's time for the white to
spread its own wings day by day
if you want to make the audio that'd be
sick but we need a new name
a new name for lawyer and that's up to
you guys
the biggest rated i will change the
subreddit name on i don't know if i can
do that
but i will here the speed standard
dragon without dying also puked i was
pooping and forgot to pause
yeah i was so surprised i wasn't dead
my character was literally on fire oh
[ __ ] i'm alive
awesome that thing is not going in my
ass that's just
not happening
raise your hand i knew i had to review
that i guess i have to wipe my ass
i mean that was the point all right
danny
go go crazy
it's a little it's a little hard but now
it was for testing that's different get
out of here
my point still stains
okay i'll admit what happened i'm not
even trolling
i'm using my [ __ ] phone you can't
even see it
it's on top of the tripod for some
reason my camera doesn't want to
work with my software today and i
couldn't be bothered figuring it out
so i plugged in my phone but i think it
looks better
i think it looks good i'm a blue that's
why i try again well you're just dark
magician
come on you can't cut it off
mid-sentence and say that it's terrible
[ __ ] it i didn't want to do we i thought
it was funny but okay
sure sure well we have some fire bars
dropping soon epic
[Laughter]
there's there's something about the
shape of them that i i like them
there is a concerning amount of footage
of me sucking up microphones but they
are always in your face
what am i supposed to do lenovo made a
demonstrated gaming chair that has a
katana built in that's sick
oh i should just add that i just need
the katana holder
clutch clutch chairs calling clutch
chairs can you make me a katana holder
please
police because i have the pewdiepie
katana
oh that'd be so sick [ __ ] lenovo suck my
dick lenovo
clutch chairs okay
[Laughter]
i got i got stuck on the at at-fer and
then i just like what is the meme and
then i like
oh okay that's funny yeah there's been
no rick roll so far
this is the first lawyer no rickroll
suck it you're not gonna get me this
time because i know
i bet this video has it in the end oh it
doesn't god bless you big peepee
yo we need answers felix do you dream in
swedish or english i thought i said this
martin says that i if i ever speak what
is it called you speak during sleep
i do it in swedish which is weird that's
weird because i think
99 of the time in english
but then again sometimes if i do
something that relates to a swedish
thing like if i write down a note
regarding my
parents or something like oh call your
parents i tend to write it
in swedish it's kind of weird and
counting i tend to do in swedish too
when i count my epic reps
goes in jubilee just so pewdiepie can
bully me hey
i don't bully people i couldn't say that
honestly could i
i don't know what is this i'm glad
jubilee is back in the studio i'm happy
i'm happy to know this
okay wait she asked the director when a
pewdiepie juvent collab was coming and
she said felix didn't respond i did we
have we're in touch
we're speaking we spoke it and for the
record
i emailed them twice and they didn't
respond
okay but yeah i'm excited for it it's
coming up uh
don't ask when because i don't know
okay so what happened it was not even a
troll i'll i'll admit it
sai was away right he still edited the
video
but i did a second cut on it and
for some reason my preset in premiere
was set to like 480p
i don't know why it doesn't just render
out in the same format
as i edited it as default but uh this is
what came out and i didn't
i didn't double check it we're all about
quality here on the pewdiepie channel in
case you haven't noticed
and for the record like i'm obviously
memeing the quality thing this episode i
will fix it next time but i also don't
know why everyone cares
obviously it's nice to watch a video
with good quality but i mean
i think it i think it looks fine i don't
really see the problem
everyone's so obsessed with quality and
[ __ ] my camera quality is better than
his
and he has more subs than me this is not
fair
like that's not how youtube works
dumbass i spend
way more time and money looking into
camera equipment why does he
shut up i've gotten so much throughout
the years by other youtubers who's bit
about my quality and
like it's like why do you care just
upload your own videos with your quality
great so yeah i'm taking a stance this
is my quality
from now on [ __ ] you hey pips
you can get the red black whites by
placing alternate black glazed
terracotta blocks facing up to that
that's kind of cool that's kind of sick
but it's more that's more stripes come
on that's more stripes
but a cool tip can pewdiepie talos fans
get in here
i've done videos in swedish and
everyone's like what the [ __ ]
i don't understand i remember the first
time i realized was eight years ago
when i did this happy wheels in swedish
commentary because everyone
asked about it look i even liked it
myself because i was so upset about it
i spent all this time subtitling the
whole video
and it got disliked bomb i never get
this is a lot of dislikes for me
okay can you make it in swedish okay
sure sure i'll do it
i don't understand him what that
guy i'll get it all right how do i how
does my swedish sound hey
jesus christ i had a i had a foul tongue
back then
okay okay
i can't even translate hey i'll discuss
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's just see i like holds i can't do
this it's too weird it's too cringe
what if i what if i switch to swedish i
just get like a really corpse voice
audience
felix does one push-up felix i can feel
my back
crack come on i gotta be able to do it
otherwise what's the point
okay one arm
i gotta warm up with how do i have the
them
i don't get it
i can't do it maybe these are the left
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you i don't want to do it
i don't feel like doing it
so pissed off now i want to ask felix to
play a game he loved i posted it
on reddit and got into hawaii i'm not
playing that never again
people got so mad i'm sorry
it's just i've seen so many people ask
me to play it
like all the time and i already said i
don't really feel like it
and then people keep asking me it's like
ah i'm not playing yet i only just said
it
i didn't realize saying you're not gonna
play a game it's like a personal insult
oh yeah [ __ ] i thought end rods was like
super rare and you can only get them in
n cities but you can literally just
crack them
god damn it thank you though i fixed
the 480p video using air
it looks a bit like airbrushed almost
but the switch was kind of cool so we
thought hey let's do that again
hey we reacted to it absolutely hey
that's kind of sick
i used my parents camera back then you
reacted to the video oh no way
nick best strong man so funny definitely
give it a watch
i thought it was super funny oh dylan
all grown up now
dude i got is this weird nick best
strong man
this is obviously a seven-year-old video
that i reacted to but
everyone was saying that nick is such a
good dude
shout out to nick best he's the best all
i want to know if
dylan is red well god damn
tlc world's smallest family nice
i was literally thinking when i reacted
to that video how he must be cringing
at his form imagine the form being on
the internet forever
that's the one that could literally
can't do a one-armed push-up god damn it
hold back on your heels and stand up
pull back oh dylan
dylan is your back okay we need answers
that's cool though shout out to nick
bess
and his family when norwin sweden get to
sit next to each other at the u.n
you ever notice denmark looks like
batman getting sucked off by a fish
where's the fish wait i don't see it
[Music]
don't look up what sweden looks like if
you combine it with finland and denmark
don't
don't look that up either there was this
whole controversy how sweden looks like
a rod dude
the euro biggest brain move of norway
they played as like a damn fool
[Laughter]
not it's not even a troll at this point
god damn it
i could tell sai was on vacation and
pierce had to edit it all now slime
still edited it but i
i managed to get up anyway somehow
[Music]
no no we need to do a blindfold taste
test because i guarantee you
the pewdiepie flavor is the best flavor
it's like tasting heaven
it's like drinking straight out of
watercast water how it started
how it ended well i'm still playing
minecraft and i still
really like it i gotta build more
automatic farms for my automatic sorting
system
[Music]
i [ __ ] knew it all right for those
who don't know we i did a leg reveal
last y live the y uh it was a terrible
mistake making that
live because it nuked all the views and
no one saw my big reveal
so i'm gonna make my reveal again
i don't feel like it if this video gets
a million likes i'll like reveal at last
in next video thank you for watching
another lawyer just thanks for watching
my videos i really appreciate it
i'm i'm still amazed by the fact that
i'm still making videos
and enjoying it and the y is a huge part
of that so
i appreciate you guys
[Music]
okay see you tomorrow bye bye